(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Em algumas matrículas de imóveis que estão indo
a leilão, vocês não vão encontrar a informação
da consolidação da propriedade em nome do credor,
e sim vocês vão encontrar a informação de
que ocorreu uma dação em pagamento.
De uma forma geral, o que é dação
em pagamento?
Dação em pagamento é um acordo entre credor
e devedor, onde o credor aceita receber bem
diverso do que ele imaginou que iria receber
para pagamento de uma dívida.
Como é que isso aplica em alienação fiduciária?
A gente falou anteriormente que na alienação fiduciária,
um imóvel é dado como garantia, e que
caso o devedor atrase o pagamento daquela dívida,
o credor poderá então constituir o devedor em
mora.
Constituir em mora nada mais é do que
falar que aquele devedor está devendo, que ele
está oficialmente devendo e que ele deve pagar
aquela dívida, ele deve purgar a mora.
Quando o credor notifica o devedor para purgar
a mora, o devedor terá um prazo de
15 dias para fazer aquele pagamento.
Então se ele não pagar, o credor necessariamente
vai consolidar a propriedade em seu nome e
obrigatoriamente vai realizar um leilão.
Agora vamos imaginar que no prazo de uma
alienação fiduciária, nesse prazo de 15 dias que
o devedor tenha para pagar, o credor, o
devedor chega até o credor e fale, olha,
aquele contrato que inicialmente eu fiz com você,
aquele valor que me comprometi a pagar, por
algum motivo eu não vou conseguir mais pagar
daqui em diante, eu poderia até colocar o
pagamento em dia agora e o contrato de
alienação fiduciária seguiria, mas daqui a alguns meses
eu vou novamente atrasar esse contrato, você novamente
vai ter que fazer o processo de me
constituir em mora, falar que eu estou devendo,
abrir um prazo para que eu pague o
que eu estou devendo e eu não vou
ter como cumprir isso daqui em diante.
Então eu quero te propor um acordo, você
fica com esse imóvel que eu dei em
garantia e extingui a minha dívida, eu não
te devo mais nada, em troca eu te
dou o imóvel.
O credor ele é obrigado a aceitar esse
tipo de acordo?
Não, em nenhum caso e aqui não vale
especificamente só para alienação fiduciária, em nenhum caso
que ocorra na vida em que alguém tem
o direito a receber um valor de outra
pessoa, essa pessoa que tem o direito a
receber, ela nunca pode ser obrigada a receber
um bem diverso ao que ela teria direito,
ainda que esse bem seja de valor mais
elevado, ou seja, você me deve 10 mil,
você chega para mim e fala olha, eu
não tenho os 10 mil em dinheiro, mas
eu tenho um carro, pode ser que esse
carro ele tenha uma cotação de mais de
10 mil reais, mas em momento algum eu
sou obrigada a concordar em receber esse carro
e o mesmo vale para alienação fiduciária, o
credor ele não é obrigado a receber esse
bem da ação em pagamento, ele não é
obrigado a ficar com esse bem para que
a dívida seja extinta, ele pode ou não
concordar com essa proposta do devedor, mas existem
muitos casos em que o credor ele concorda,
ele fala então me dá o bem, então
me dá esse móvel para cá e essa
dívida morre comigo e existem casos na alienação
fiduciária que o credor então ele vai concordar,
ele vai pegar o bem sem precisar fazer
aquele procedimento de consolidação da propriedade, vai ser
um acordo entre credor e devedor, pode ser
até mesmo que esse acordo ele nasça antes
do devedor ele ser constituído em mora, pode
ser que o devedor chegue em algum momento
e fale assim, eu não vou ter como
pagar esse financiamento daqui para frente, já vou
procurar logo meu credor para ver o que
a gente consegue fazer, não necessariamente tem que
respeitar essa constituição do devedor em mora, não
necessariamente o devedor ele vai ter que ser
notificado para falar que ele está em atraso,
ele pode fazer isso antes, então na dação
em pagamento, na alienação fiduciária, o credor ele
vai aceitar ficar com o imóvel para extinguir
a dívida do devedor e aí como é
que o credor ele vai fazer a venda
desse bem né, porque a partir do momento
que ele aceita a dação em pagamento o
bem é dele, ele não precisa seguir os
requisitos da lei 9.514 para alienar aquele
bem, ele não vai precisar fazer um primeiro
leilão, ele não vai precisar fazer no segundo
leilão, ele não vai ter que notificar o
devedor da existência de algum leilão caso ele
faça a opção por vender esse imóvel por
um leilão, então como é que ele vai
vender?
Ele vai vender da forma que a gente
acabou de estudar na aula anterior, na aula
anterior a gente falou de como é que
um credor ele vende um bem se não
for arrematado em primeiro e segundo leilão, a
gente falou que pode existir um terceiro leilão,
pode existir a venda direta, no caso da
caixa econômica pode existir ainda a licitação aberta
e a licitação fechada, então esse mesmo procedimento
ele pode ocorrer no caso de uma dação
em pagamento, o credor ele vai escolher a
forma como ele vai vender aquele bem pelo
valor que ele quiser vender aquele bem, o
bem é dele, ele faz o que ele
quiser com aquele bem, não tem que seguir
a lei 9.514, a maioria dos credores
fiduciários como a gente já falou várias vezes
aqui são bancos e aí entra no mesmo
caso da venda pós segundo leilão, não é
interessante para o banco ter aquele imóvel em
seu estoque, o banco quer o dinheiro, então
o banco quer vender aquele bem, então no
caso da ação em pagamento os credores fiduciários
e sua grande maioria bancos vão escolher vender
esse bem e podem adotar uma das formas
que a gente falou na aula anterior, eles
podem realizar um leilão, eles podem colocar em
venda direta ou pode ainda, se for o
caso da caixa, entrar em licitação aberta ou
licitação fechada, então tenha sempre em mente que
caso você encontre em um leilão uma matrícula
que não tem consolidação da propriedade, mas tem
dação em pagamento, você tem que saber que
a dação em pagamento significa que o devedor
como forma de pagamento da dívida ele deu
aquele imóvel ao credor e o credor aceitou
essa forma de pagamento, porque o credor não
seria obrigado a aceitar ainda que esse bem
tenha um valor acima do que ele deveria
receber, ele não é obrigado, mas o credor
nesse caso aceitou, concordou e o credor então
vai ser o dono definitivo daquele imóvel e
ele pode vender o imóvel da forma como
ele preferir, não precisa seguir o que a
lei 9.514 diz, então ele não precisa
fazer o primeiro leilão, não precisa fazer o
segundo leilão e não precisa notificar o devedor
dessa venda, ele pode fazer da forma como
ele preferir, na maioria dos casos os credores
fiduciários escolhem botar a venda direta ou escolhem
realizar um leilão.
Quais são as vantagens de comprar um imóvel
com dação em pagamento?
A maioria desses imóveis que está com dação
em pagamento, ele está desocupado, por quê?
Não faz sentido o devedor chegar ao credor
e propor um acordo para dar aquele imóvel
como pagamento de uma dívida e ficar morando
naquele imóvel, afinal que tipo de acordo seria
esse que traria um ônus para o credor,
porque se o devedor continuar morando naquele imóvel,
o credor teria que tirar o devedor daquele
imóvel e qual seria a forma correta de
tirar?
Entrar com o processo na justiça para que
ocorra a chamada emissão na posse, a gente
vai estudar aqui um pouco mais na frente
as formas de desocupação de um imóvel em
leilão excrujudicial, mas aí nesse caso dação em
pagamento, o banco teria que utilizar a mesma
forma como se existisse a consolidação na propriedade,
então não faz sentido você propor um acordo
para alguém e nesse acordo você gerar um
ônus para alguém, então a partir do momento
que o devedor ele faz um acordo de
dação em pagamento com aquele credor, ele vai
desocupar aquele bem, o credor ele vai fazer
essa exigência, eu aceito o bem em dação
em pagamento desde que você desocupe aquele bem
e ele pode incluir algumas outras exigências nesse
acordo que eles vão fazer e o credor
fiduciário que aceitar o bem como dação em
pagamento, para ele alienar esse bem, ele também
deve necessariamente passar esse bem livre de ônus,
ônus de IPTU e ônus de condomínio, porque
vai aplicar a mesma regra que a gente
falou na aula anterior, quando o credor fiduciário
ele pega um imóvel que ele recebeu em
dação em pagamento, ele coloca a venda, é
como se estivesse fazendo uma venda entre particulares,
então essa venda ela tem que ser livre
de ônus, a não ser que você concorde
em receber um imóvel com aquele ônus, mas
se você não concordar, ela tem que ser
livre de ônus, então na maioria dos leilões
que são realizados, quando o banco recebe um
bem em dação em pagamento, esse banco ele
vai ter que repassar esse bem livre de
débitos de IPTU e condomínio, não existe a
chance de quem comprar aquele bem arcar com
isso, agora se você se deparar com casos
de dação em pagamento, verifique né, só confirme
se existe expressa previsão de que esse bem
vai ser transmitido sem ônus, para que você
não possa correr o risco de arrematar um
imóvel e depois existir alguma cobrança de IPTU
e condomínio contra você, então tenha sempre isso
em mente, dação em pagamento é perfeitamente válido,
nada mais significa do que o devedor pagar
a dívida que ele tem com o credor
com aquele imóvel, então ele vai dar de
cara aquele imóvel para o credor e o
credor vai alienar o bem da forma como
ele preferir, pelo valor que ele preferir e
da maneira como ele preferir.